what technological advances would be
needed to prevent our sun from expanding
and how close are we to obtaining that
technology all right there is a way to
prolong the life of a star and if we
were ever to do that for the sun because
our civilization would somehow outlive
the life expectancy of most mammals the
mammal life expectancy is about 3
million years
and on average and we're a mammal so
unless we figure out a way to beat those
odds we're we're toast for one reason or
another after on average three million
years so i love talking to you always
still uplifting the sun's got another
five billion years left so we'd have to
prolong our lives until the sun is ready
to die and then prolong the life of the
sun so one way to do that is it's got
hydrogen in the center converting it to
helium right that's the thermonuclear
fusion there's a lot of hydrogen in the
outer layers that never makes it to the
center
so when the sun runs out of helium it
only runs out of helium in the center
and so what you need is a way to channel
helium from the outer layers deep down
into the center to give it fresh supply
you do that the sun could live 100
billion years oh my god no question
about it so you would basically just
have to funnel helium back to the no no
i'm sorry did i say hello and hydrogen
hydrogen hydrogen in the outer layers
okay because it's converting hydrogen
into helium
all these outer layers you bring it back
in you prolong the life of the sun uh
just that before the break we talk about
prolonging the life of the sun right all
you have to do is churn fresh fuel which
lives in the outer layers down into the
center right and we know this works
because there are stars that collide
with one another and when you collide
you you mix your materials and stars
have a fresh birth
simply because all the helium that it
collected in the center as as as
leftover
byproduct all gets mixed back into the
star and fresh hydrogen shows up in the
middle and that's how and then you have
a new new life to the star now just
seems to me if we have the power to
prolong the life of the sun by churning
its contents we have the power just move
to another damn solar system
if we can do that move to mars or
jupiter's moons you know i mean so there
might be other options available than
messing with the sun like making the
earth a spaceship and just actually
leaving yeah keep the whole earth intact
hey a headphone just take it someplace
else i mean hey if we can manipulate the
sun we can do that right you can do that
but you need an energy source on route
so you got to like get cozy until you
get to another uh
solar system so that i don't think that
far ahead
oh